ندى حجازي وقفتنا اليوميه مع مراسل لصباح
العربيه ندى عندها خبر عن شنو عن جينات
المصريين
وازمه كليوباترا ندى
جيناتك قريبه من كليوباترا ولا بعيده صباح
الخير صباح الورد
الله
[ضحك]
شو تفاصيل الخبر يا ندى
طبعا هو مؤخرا فريق من الباحثين المصريين
وضحوا ان ان صناع الوثائقي من نتفليكس
فضلوا اكثر الاعتماد على روايات المؤرخين
الكلاسيكيين عن الاستعانه بخبراء التاريخ
الهيليستي واليوناني الروماني وانهم حصدوا
ما يقرب من 2000 عينه للاوصاف الجسديه
للسلاله المصريه من حيث نوع الشعر شكل
العيون شكل الانف لون البشره وده طبعا
بالاعتماد كمان على ورق البردي وشواهد
القبور ولوحات وجوه الموتى
وان يعني العينات دي وضحت انه
اصحاب البشره الداكنه او الذنوب كان عددهم
قليل جدا في السلاله المصريه فبالتالي هي
كانت بعيده عن ال ااا
الابطال بتوع الوثائقي وان كمان يعني
الملكه كليوباترا كانت من اكتر الملكات
اللي نقشت صورتها على العملات اللي اض
الشرعيه على حكمها في الوقت ده فكان لها
صور كتير جدا واضحه والصور دي بعيده تماما
عن اختيار نتفليكس للابطال ده كمان خلى
فريق من القانونيين يلاحق نتفليكس ويطلب
بتعويضه 2 مليار دولار بتهمه تشويه
التاريخ المصري والغزو والاعلامي والثقافي
على الحضاره المصريه
ايضا يعني عمل
بوثائقي ونشر على اليوتيوب وكذلك الناس عم
تتحدث يعني دائما نوبيه مش نوبيه طيب هذه
قصه كليوباترا مثيره لكن في فتاه مثيره
ايضا للجدل على تيك توك ايه حكايه تيك توك
طبعا هو في دلوقتي اكتر من قضيه معموله
لاكتر من بلوجر او تيك توك زي ما بنقول
عليهم
فمؤخرا تم تقييد حكم حبس البلوجر موكا
حجازي لمده سنه بتهمه تورطها في اعمال
منافيه للاداب ونشر مقاطع فيديو عبر
حساباتها على السوشيال ميديا فاضحه وغير
ملائمه وده يعني يعني زود الاستمرار في
اثاره الجدل حوالين القانون نفسه يعني في
خبراء قانونين ومحاميين بيطالبوا فقط
بتوضيح المواد القانونيه دي علشان يكون
صناع المحتوى اللي اغلبهم سنهم صغير جدا
بينهم يفهموا ايه لائق وايه اللي غير لائق
وايه اللي ممكن
يدخلهم السجن وايه اللي لا وان تكون
المواد دي بتحقق الموازنه بين التنظيم
المحتوى اللي اكيد ضروري جدا في مجتمع زي
مصر وفي نفس الوقت يكون فيه مساحه من
الحريه علشان
يقدروا ان هم يبتكروا في عالم كبير ومفتوح
زي
كان معنى الاسبوع الماضي ايضا في فقره ما
وضد فيما يتعلق بقانون اذا كنت اذا بتذكر
بشكل دقيق قانون حمايه القيم الاسريه اللي
على اساسه بيتم اعتقال او على الاقل يعني
القبض على
مشاهير التيك توك شكرا كليوباترا صباح
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات